we've been looking at projectile motion
when we take air resistance
into account and i want to pick up from
this moment in
our working where you may recall we took
the particular result for
uh the second derivative of uh vertical
motion with respect to time
given these particular restraints and
then we sort of did a bit of
simplification with our particular value
of g
particular value of k then we landed on
this spot
and in our you know work through the
lesson i said
this looks a whole lot like the same
differential equation we had for
horizontal motion
and that was an exponential decay
situation right
and from that i drew this equation
together
it's exponential decay just like you saw
before because you've got this
exponential
that negative sign indicates decay
rather than growth
but i said that the difference was as
compared to horizontal motion
this 50 in here uh introduced
essentially a
shift into our um our exponential decay
situation we're not moving towards zero
anymore
we're going to be uh changed by this
offset of 50 units
now if you're like me when you have a
look at this move
this is certainly one of those what just
happened moments right
um it's one of those moments i actually
find most frustrating when i'm reading a
textbook
and it kind of pulls this just trust me
uh move on you
where it does not look immediately
obvious unless you are much smarter than
i am
uh to go from this first line here from
the
differential equation which relates
acceleration uh vertically
with uh velocity vertically and then to
pull this
rabbit out of a hat this is a time
equation for
velocity how do we get to this can we
actually show this
from from first principles that's what i
want to show you now so that you don't
just have to accept
that this magically comes from this
equation i want to show you
exactly all of the moves the calculus
that we can use to actually show
why this result is the case so what i'm
going to do
is i'm actually going to take us back a
couple of steps go back to essentially
what we got here in the question with g
and k
being unspecified i'm going to show it i
think it's actually easier to do some of
the numbers when you don't have so many
uh constants flying around
um and you can also see in some of our
results where the gravity comes in
where the constant of proportionality
ends up um through our integration
process
so we're gonna go from here this is
going to be our starting point i'm going
to show you
how you end up here and then you can
sort of take it from where we did it in
the lesson
all right so for starters what do i want
to say out of this
well i need to get to what a time
equation right so therefore i'm going to
rework this equation um with the form of
acceleration over here
that includes time in it and also makes
it easier for me to use this y dot this
velocity
vertical velocity um term in here right
now remembering that if i would normally
say that you know if i had
acceleration in just like a normal
straight line situation i would normally
write that as dv
on dt change in velocity over time if
all i had to worry about was a single
direction
v velocity is just fine it's sufficient
but here in this projectile motion
situation because we're considering it
two dimensionally
that's why we've got an x dot and a y
dot so here
rather than you know this um being just
vaguely
acceleration this is y double dot and
sort of carrying over here
it would not be dv on dt it would be d
vertical velocity over dt so therefore
the way that i would write this
slightly awkward but i think it's going
to be the
most succinct and also the least
ambiguous way to describe what's going
on
this is not d y uh sorry dv on dt it's d
y dot on dt so this is just my
expression
for vertical velocity and then i have
the rest of the differential equation
on the right hand side like so
okay so from here what do i want to pull
well i'm going to
try and pull off this same kind of
separation and variables trick that i've
done
many times before because that will let
me actually integrate
so um i can see i've got my
i've got these terms over here and i
want to divide through by those and then
this dt is going to end up on my
you know on the other side so that i can
actually integrate successfully
so therefore what i'm going to do is i
think what might be easiest is to
actually put this into a single fraction
so i'm going to go
negative 1 outside of i don't know i've
put that
over there in the middle negative 1
outside of g
plus k y like so
and the left hand side hasn't changed
and what this enables me to do
excuse me is to take the reciprocal and
then i can integrate appropriately so
you can see if i go
dt on d y dot
here that's going to give me uh the
reciprocal of negative 1 is just
negative 1 so i'll leave that at the top
then i'm going to get my g plus k
y dot on the denominator and from here
you can see i'm going to get a log on
the right hand side once i integrate
with respect to the correct
variable so what i'm going to do to make
that a bit more obvious is say
i'm going to put the minus
k multiply through by that dt
and that's going to give me a positive k
on
g plus k y dot with respect to
y dot so you can see what i've done
there is i have
rearranged this d y dot has come over
to the right hand side and in addition
to that
if i just highlight here i've multiplied
through this negative 1
by negative k giving me k over here
so that i have this f dash on f
situation but of course you can't just
multiply the you know the right hand
side by negative k you've also got to
multiply the left hand side
by negative k all right so now this is
ready to actually just
integrate i'm ready to go so on the left
hand side this is going to be a linear
function so minus
kt because i'm integrating with respect
to time plus my constant which i'm going
to find out in a second
and then on the right hand side i got
this ready to go as a log and it's just
g
plus k y dot i don't need another
constant because i've got it captured
all over here
in my left hand constant okay having
integrated i'm now going to use my
initial conditions
to evaluate this constant and if i go
back to this question
you can see i'm thinking about vertical
motion at this point
and there the j vector is going to be
multiplied by 30 so there is my initial
vertical
velocity it's going to be 30 meters per
second i guess
um because i don't have any other units
i'm just going to assume meters per
second
up in the vertical direction so i can
say
initially or you could have said um
time equals zero
and the y dot the vertical
motion uh velocity that i start with is
going to be 30. so let's go ahead and
just substitute that in
i'm going to get 0 plus c on left hand
side
and then log of g
plus this is where i've got my
value of k here which is actually i
might as well just put in at this point
because this will let me simplify a
little bit g is 10 as has been set in
the question
i've got a k of a fifth and that's
multiplied by the
30 which i was substituting in to here
there's that value there appearing all
the way
through okay so from here you can see
i've just got the constant on the left
hand side and then i've got log of
10 plus a fifth of 30 last i checked was
6 so therefore i'm going to get 10 plus
6
which is 16 over there on the right hand
side
okay so now i can um substitute that
back in i can say
therefore i'm going to put in since i
used it here to evaluate i'm going to
put in k
and i'm going to put in c and i'm going
to put in g so what expression does that
give me or equation rather
it looks to me like i'm going to get
minus
a fifth of t plus my constant which is
log of
16 is equal to log of
10 plus y dot all divided by
5. okay let's just have a look there
i've substituted in k i've substituted
in c
i substitute in g it's all looking good
and at this point you remember where i'm
headed towards is an equation for y
dot so i need to rearrange this quite
substantially
to try and show that what's the best way
to do this well
for starters what i'm going to do is
i'll leave the um
yeah i'll leave the left hand side as it
is for the briefest moment
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
get everything in here onto
a single denominator because you know
it's two terms and
it's going to make my log laws a bit
easier to manipulate in a second
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
say this is equal to
50 plus y dot
all divided by 5.
and then from there what i'm going to do
is i'm going to subtract that log 16
from both sides so that gives me minus t
on 5 on the left hand side and then log
of
this whole term here and i'm going to
subtract
log 16. but remember uh log laws this is
what i was saying before
when you subtract logs what you're doing
is you're dividing by
the numbers that you're taking the log
of so in this case it would be this
inside part here
divided by 16. so when you divide
that's going to change our denominator
here
50 plus y dot that's all divided through
by 5 times 16
which last i checked was 80 and i've got
minus t
on 5 on the left hand side okay
i'm almost there you can see here that
this this ln
is just log base e so now i can rewrite
this whole logarithmic equation
as an exponential equation so that's
going to give me
i'm going to take this inside the log
that's going to become my new subject of
the equation and it's going to be e
to the power of minus t on 5.
okay fantastic so from there i can say
that's going to be multiply through by
80
e to the minus t on 5 that's 50 plus y
dot
on the left hand side and now i just
need to subtract
50 and there it is i've got my vertical
velocity
with respect to time and no hand waving
required you can see exactly where
things came from i did the integration
um you had to be fairly careful to get
your log right and watch out for those
minus signs
and then there's the results so you can
see if i compare this
to the result that i kind of did uh
earlier on in our lesson
um you can see there it's the same
exponential function it's got that shift
there
and then you just have to go and use the
same kind of initial conditions that we
did
in this result to find out what your
value of c is which we already have
determined
is 80. so if this particular step here
it kind of fizzled your brain and you're
like but why is that the case well now
you have
the y this is doing it sort of deriving
that result from first principles
and it's important you know why that is
and how to be able to do this yourself
because
uh you know it's often the case number
one that you'll be required to show that
and number two
if you just can't remember that this
just magically turns into this
you've got to be able to work your way
out of it nonetheless so i hope that
working
made sense to you if it's unclear just
let me know happy to answer any
questions